مع الارن من موسكو مراسلات مازن عباس مازن
اهلا ومرحبا بك معنا امازن ماذا عن تفاصيل
تصريحات الرئيس الروسيه
كان الرئيس الروسي كما ذكرتي تحدث عن ان
الهجوم المضاده للاوكراني
منير خسائر كبيره فادح في الارواح
والمعدات وان اكثر من 70000 جندي اوكراني
خلال هذه الهجمات ايضا تحدث عن انه روما
انداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الغربيه سواء
العنقوديه ذات المحترم لن تغير في مسار
العمليات العسكريه ولن تغير في نتائج هذه
العمليات لانه يشعر بالقلق لانه لم يعد
هناك قيود في استخدام هذه الاسلحه حدث
ايضا عن ان هناك بعض الاوكران الذين تم
اعتقالهم اعترفوا بانهم تلقوا تدريبات في
بريطانيا تحدث عن انه لا يمكن لروسيا ان
تتخذ قرار منفرد بايقاف العمليات العسكريه
طالما ان الطرف الاخر يستمر في عمليته
العسكريه وبالتالي يعني هي مضطره للدفاع
عن نفسها والتعامل والحمايه الاراضي
الروسيه واخيرا اشار الى انه لابد من
اجراء
النظر بشكل واقعي وموضوعي للوضع الراهن
والتاجراء تغييرات في المواقف بحيث يمكن
استئناف المفاوضات لان الرفض الاوكراني
اعتبره بوتين لا لا يقوم على اي اساس
موضوعي واقعي وهو عمليا انصياع للاراده
الامريكيه التي لا تهتم كثيرا بما يحدث في
الاقليم وانما لتاجيل هذا الصراع في
محاوله منها لدرجه روسيا وتثبيتها وايضا
صار عليها اشكرك يا مازن على كل هذه
التفاصيل كنت معنا مباشره من موسكو